Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast at all.
I'm checking in on Ya.
She has chicken.
Um,
how are you?
Oh,
fucking a bulla.
Billy is back
and he's feeling better than ever.
No more coughing fits.
No more night sweats,
no more sleeping under a mosquito net with my fucking malaria.
Um,
I don't think malaria is a funny reference considering each year
42% of women on the planet suffer from this while the men are giving endless
supplies of Nyquil.
Oh,
here's something I started to talk about the other day on one of my podcasts.
What am I,
many rambling nonsensical or whatever the fuck you say podcasts.
Um,
out here in Los Angeles,
Hollywood specifically,
there's a group of people that want to get the Hollywood sign taken down because
they live near the Hollywood sign and there's too many fucking tourists.
I just don't like that has got to be one of the most fucked up things I've ever
heard in my life.
Like the whole city has to suffer,
you know,
while you take down this iconic sign because you were dumb enough to buy a house
next to a tourist attraction,
you fucking moron.
Wait,
why don't you just buy a house across from the fucking magic castle?
Whatever the fuck they call it down there at Disneyland and then get upset,
you know,
uh,
we need to shut down Disneyland.
There's too many people walking around with like Mickey Mouse ears on.
It's almost like I bought a house right across from fucking Disneyland.
I could see if it was a new,
like since you bought the house that uh,
you know,
all of a sudden they put this new fucking thing up and you're like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Hey,
hey,
wait a minute.
This was a quiet neighborhood when I bought the house.
This is why I bought the house and all of a sudden there's all these fucking
people.
Huh?
People love it that,
that,
that's fucking sign it.
It's like 80 something years old,
right.
The fucking sign is probably as old as your house.
I don't know what the problem is.
Let me just look this up here.
Hollywood sign history.
I used to be called the Hollywood land bag of the day.
Yeah,
it was Hollywood land.
I mean,
I think to actually think that the native Americans put it up.
If I'm not doing it might probably say something else like Hiawatha or some
native American shit is actually native American shooters at some white
Hollywood shit.
The history of the Hollywood sign.
Okay.
Assigned born in Ninth 1923 that fucking thing has been around and then some
asshole with a house that was built in fucking 1978 that they just bought in
2016 wants to fucking thing taken down.
All right.
Nobody gives a shit about the history of the sign all the way maybe people do.
Signs on was a hundred years old.
It's fitting that the Hollywood sign,
the worldwide symbol of the entertainment industry was conceived as an outdoor
ad campaign for a suburban housing development called Hollywood land.
After all,
despite the high profile of the film is real estate has always been Hollywood's
primary economic driver.
Although the signs with the fight,
the,
no,
it hasn't.
You needed the entertainment industry so it could make stars so they could
afford all these fucking houses.
Who the fuck would move out here just to live into a in a fucking house with all
of this traffic.
All right.
Although the signs of parents of purpose has evolved over the years,
it's basic.
It's aspirational.
Message remains the same.
This is the place where magic is possible,
where dreams can come true,
and these fucking people that lived there,
the side want to take this down,
Huh?
Back then the dream was beautiful,
was a beautiful home and lifestyle.
Today the signs promise is more subtle and can only be described as the parade
of images,
desires and ideas conjured by the word Hollywood.
I think that there fucking looking into this a little bit too much.
No,
Hollywood and you come out here because you want to fucking star in movies or
write movies that direct them,
you know,
and to take advantage of your position of power,
act like an animal and then have the whole fucking thing come crumbling down.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's what's,
that's what's been going on since we've been out here.
Uh,
take down,
Holly would sign search.
She's the Hollywood sign.
Okay.
Christine O'Brien.
Yeah.
Pesticided I guess nobody in La should get to look at that fucking awesome sign
anymore.
All right.
There's a woman who wants to get rid of the Hollywood sign.
I can't blame the impulse.
It looks so good.
Attacked by tornadoes in aliens.
What does such a rash,
such a rush in the slow creek and the quick crunch of the corrugated letters
peel from the scaffolding and fly off from mountain.
Whoa.
The fuck wrote all this shit.
The worldwide fame of the sign is bolted to that image of just of its
destruction.
Right.
Hey,
Christina.
Brian though suggest taking the sign down and moving it to universal studios on
the other side of the hill are wrecking the context lists h at some sort of
tourist trap in the flats of Hollywood.
She lives in the signs.
Original namesake.
Hollywood land.
Yeah.
The sign once read Hollywood land.
Does that mean our houses where land used to be
this person?
Are they really smarter?
There's English as second language.
She lives in the signs.
Original namesake.
Does that mean she lives in Hollywood?
Yeah,
a small,
steep,
disorienting neighborhood where big houses hugged the streets in front and hang
off into nothing in the back.
Hollywood lands,
ness of streets rise out from the top of Beachwood.
Jesus.
This fucking verbose count.
All right.
The strangest thing about the Hollywood sign is that everyone let a huge real
estate advertisement slowly rot on one of the city's most prominent peaks for 55
years from when it was planted on the hillside by Hollywood Land Realty Company
in 1923 until it was dug up and replaced in 1978 slowly accruing meaning and
sentiment over the same decades.
Uh,
Los Angeles was earning its reputation as a place that was happy to demolish its
own brief pass.
Dude,
is this the weirdest right person writing ever?
It's like,
it just a contradicts itself.
I can't even read this shit.
All right,
let's,
let me just go back here.
Hollywood sign hiking to the sign.
The Hollywood sign.
Hollywood sign knocked down.
Here's the best way.
Hollywood signed.
Trail closure is long overdue.
Hang on a second here.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
This is just all fucking interesting to me.
They got somebody with this selfie stick.
That's not really,
that's not a good argument for the other side.
I just don't get people that fucking bought houses up there.
Like what did you think was going to fucking happen?
And like how much money do you fucking have and how much of a cunt or you just
move it to the other side.
I actually think,
to be honest with you,
the fact that someone would want to take that side down is a clear example of
the,
of,
of the disappearing middle class.
They don't want these animals going up there.
These lower class people walking around.
They fucking
Goddamn walled off house.
All right.
Why is it long overdue?
It was a great hike.
All right.
In the span of about 10 minutes,
so,
and soak and hike from a paved road in the Hollywood hills,
Beachwood Canyon neighborhood to take a breathtaking view of breath,
uh,
Griffith Park,
the city skyline,
and of course the Hollywood side.
When I have the free time,
I always like to come here.
Nobody gives a shit.
But after this weekend,
uh,
she will lose her quick,
quick escape to urban life.
Starting Tuesday,
the Beachwood drive will be closed to public because of court action.
Hikers and tourists will be directed away from the trail entrance.
The soon to be closed.
Trailhead is popular among Angelenos as well as tourists wanting a selfie with
the world's most famous sign,
blah,
blah.
Some residents welcomed the closure even though they,
along with other visits will no longer be able to access the trail though.
It's long overdue.
Says Jim Krantz 60,
stop it.
Yeah.
I'm an old angry guy.
Got a hair like you didn't go up there and he fucking 23 schedule with some
fucking chick back in the day and now you're too fucking old.
Legs are too old to go up the trail.
So everyone else can't go.
Great Body camera fucking shot my deck.
He did that back in the fucking well that would make them too old.
The Vietnam era,
I dunno.
Uh,
okay.
Gate.
We'll have clocking through.
Okay.
I,
I'm always walking my dog.
We'd come up here every night.
We're going to miss our little hikes up here still.
While the closure is a bummer,
it's worth that.
He said there's a classic fucking La guy is 60 years old still saying bummer.
What did you interview the fucking dude for?
To have it locked and lose all the people in all the noise and all the sound and
all of the litter and everything else that goes along with it.
Yeah.
It's not a legal challenge by residents,
but one from the sunset ranch.
Oh,
horse stabler and tour company.
Okay,
so what's the horse people that is putting an end to public access to the trail
road.
All right,
fuck it.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I thought it was the people with the houses.
Now it turns out it's a fucking rancher.
It's a matter all the selfie people have spoken your horses.
Is that what's going on?
Did I just waste 10 minutes talking about that fucking sign?
Why Bill?
Why did you waste 10 minutes?
Because you fucking team lost again last night.
Yes,
they did.
The finesse Bruins.
The goal scoring Bruins once again,
uh,
lost to the,
the pretending to be tough.
Tampa Bay lightening.
Uh,
I've been watching the Bruins for 40 years and he spent a long time since I've
seen us get pushed around the way we're getting pushed around.
And I think,
uh,
we've got too many Rick Middleton's and not enough Jay Miller's,
we need a,
we need somebody to,
I dunno,
we're just letting people waltz into the fucking zone.
And I kind of feel like after the first two games at Toronto,
Toronto made an adjustment and kind of showed how to beat the Bruins.
And I think we caught Tampa a little flat because of the layoff and we beat him
in game one and they're basically just doing the same fucking thing that Toronto
did to us,
which is,
you know what kind of a one line team right now.
I don't know,
maybe we just had a couple of games that were bad.
Um,
but it's not the Tampa scored goals.
It's that they're fucking,
all this face washing and all this shit that they're doing and now they're
starting to fucking act like did this tough team and they're not,
I mean,
I could beat up half the people to Tampa.
That's a true story.
I'm fucking with you.
I don't know.
It's just weird.
I've never seen the Bruins not saying it's happening a lot.
It's that just taken a little too many fucking liberties and um,
the calls haven't been gone our way the last two games.
So I got to feel like would do this game,
you know,
I don't want to sit here and bitch about the officiating because some nights you
get the call,
some nights you don't add a,
it's just been kind of back to back yet.
I don't know how you miss a stick hitting an eight foot guy in the face.
I don't know how you miss that.
And then you turn around and call a penalty on his retaliation and uh,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It's been a,
uh,
but generally speaking,
I don't think the officiating,
I think,
I dunno if the overthinking things,
it's just been weird.
Not as much bad,
just kind of weird officiating.
So maybe who knows?
Tonight we're dude next,
tomorrow night maybe I guess we play,
we're due to get some calls.
Uh,
however I will say this,
the,
uh,
rebuild his Ben as success.
The fact we already want to fucking play off series and we could win this one.
We can actually get to the eastern conference finals this quickly after blowing
up the team.
So I am happy about that.
I just wish we would,
uh,
we had a little more teeth,
you know,
I mean,
Tampa,
I don't look at tap.
They don't have any giant fucking goon.
They're basically a bunch of goals,
scores and a couple of fucking punks.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I dunno what the fucking deal is.
I'd like to see Nash.
Lou uses size a little more.
Fucking lay somebody out.
Even if you've got to take a pet.
Does that,
is that game gone now in hockey?
I mean,
we had our first fight last night.
Fucking unheard of.
Yeah.
Fucking 10 games in to the playoffs.
We had our first fight.
Um,
but you know,
all these people that watched Olympic hockey,
this is the hockey that they wanted so they can now sit down and watch it,
which they're not doing.
The cons,
you know,
I think the people that tried to get fighting out of hockey are also people that
want to take the Hollywood sign down.
Those kinds of people.
Oh,
by the way,
you guys keep asking me about this Michelle Wolf thing.
I haven't seen it.
I don't pay attention to the news,
but evidently she did the White House correspondence dinner and everybody's all
up in arms because he told some jokes,
which I can totally understand.
Yeah.
I mean,
she's telling jokes people.
that's,
that's how fucking dangerous is that.
You know,
it's just unbelievable to me that it's okay to,
uh,
genetically alter our food supply.
That's okay.
You can take all the fucking principles,
a heroine and,
and,
and create them in the synthetic form and create a fucking nationwide heroin
epidemic.
That's fine.
Not a word from CNN or fucking Fox on that shit.
Not a fucking peep,
right?
You can totally cook the economy,
leave millions of Americans upside down in their own fucking houses the rest of
their life.
They're going to owe more than what their house is worth.
And then you give the houses right back to the bankers so they can do it all
over again.
All of that is fine.
But evidently if you're a comedian and you tell some fucking jokes,
people are going to debate it for 10 fucking days while they're feeding kids.
They're their own fucking kids.
This poison food that's gonna make your nine year old have a fucking mustache is
fucking nuts are going to drop before he learns how to ride a bike.
It's so full of fucking hormones and all this other fucking shit.
Evidentaly that is fine.
Poisoning your own food supply,
something isis jerks off to doing to us.
I mean,
I,
those not terrorist acts against your own fucking people.
The people that did that shit should literally be hanging from their toes.
But there's not a fucking word that said about it.
Not a fucking word is said about it because they advertise on CNN and Fox and
they donate to fucking politicians.
So they don't say a fucking word.
You know,
all of these fucking presidents,
they leave the office worth tens of millions of dollars despite the fact that
they only made 500 grand a year as president.
You tell me how that math works out.
Why isn't that ever talked about the level that they do now?
When a comedian tells a fucking joke,
it's ridiculous.
Um,
I'm off my soapbox.
Jesus fucking Christ I.
This is just,
this is literally the era of just getting outraged about something that really
doesn't fucking matter.
While meanwhile,
two feet away,
there's a raging fucking inferno.
Can you believe the joke she told at that fucking place where she was hired to
tell jokes?
Can you believe she went in there and did her fucking job that make God,
that's outrageous.
Let's talk about that for 10 days and ignored the fact that the Ford Motor
Company is phasing out cars because no one buys them anymore because everybody
needs an SUV because their cars are full of shit that they don't need,
that they're eventually going to take down to goodwill and is going to end up in
the fucking ocean in that swirl of fucking trash.
Fuck all of that.
Did you hear that Caitlyn Jenner joke?
Did you hear what so and so said about Donald Trump?
Um,
this is why I don't watch the news.
This is why I just sit alone by myself and think things and agree with them and
then spew them out as though they're fucked me.
Why not?
Why can't I have my own little news network?
Why can't I behave like CNN and Fox and curate my fucking news and Spin my own
fucking angle on it and then just have Americans yelling at each other?
I Dunno.
I don't understand why people liked this.
The level of mouth breathing more on you have to be to be on Facebook right now
screaming at somebody about politics or social issues.
You know,
and even worse,
the people that totally buy into it and then start using all that fucking
corporate speak like that was microaggressive you know,
walking around like you're this informed person.
Ah,
they cannot go suck a dick.
Good for her.
She went there and told some jokes and she ruffled some feathers.
All right.
They know they're going to treat her like she's in fucking Isis.
Classic Classic Journalism in the modern era.
All right.
Um,
I've got a couple of 'em so that's what I think about that.
Okay.
I don't need to fucking watch any of the jokes.
I know she's fucking hilarious and I know that it's completely blown out of
proportion and everybody's running around like fucking chicken.
Little people with blue ties yelling at people with red fucking ties or the blue
type people like it.
Cause the red tie people got it worse or vice versa.
MMM.
Alright.
Plowing ahead here.
Okay.
Meanwhile,
there's going to be a fucking polar bear swimming up to my fucking house in
about three years.
Alright.
Put your box.
Everybody bought your box,
delivers healthy 100% grass fed and finished beef free range,
organic chicken,
a heritage,
heritage bread,
pork,
which is the pure bred pigs swine that came over here from Europe.
Okay.
Not The bastardized once that we have here that are all,
all mixed up.
All right?
These are pure pigs,
um,
to your door on a monthly basis.
You know,
it's funny that they do that with dogs and pigs,
you know what I mean?
It's like if you'd like took out dog and pig and you actually put human being in
there,
you'd sound like a grand dragon.
Uh,
all their products are human humane,
humanly,
humanely raised and never given the antibiotics are our hormones.
I gotta tell you something,
man.
I been eating that stuff all week.
It's delicious.
Absolutely delicious.
A high quality healthy protein you can trust,
unbelievable taste.
There's a huge difference in taste between animals raised on pasture and those
fed grain and concentrated animal feed lot operations.
Yeah,
that's the difference between cool kids and people with helicopter parents.
What's your box?
But actually probably sounded good example.
Um,
parents that love them versus parents that abused them,
but at the end of the day,
they do kill the animals.
So I don't think there's a lot of love there.
Put your box is changing that and they offer free shipping anywhere in the lower
48.
Um,
I liked what you said in the 48 states.
I mean,
do I get to pick which 48,
Alaska and Hawaii,
the middle children of our states,
they never did.
They just never feel like they get their dope.
Cause then I connected to us,
you know,
what do you think would happen someday if Alaska,
Hawaii and Puerto Rico all got together and decided to take on blackwater?
Now that's a fucking movie.
I would like to see,
um,
offer $20,
$20 off plus free bacon.
You get $20 off in free bacon by going to butcher
box.com/burr and using
the Discount Code Burpee,
you U R I have the hiccups now from talking about food.
Uh,
express the p n Victor Papa November.
Facebook has been in the news a lot lately,
getting thrashed for letting third parties get your user data.
Um,
but do you really think they're the only ones doing it now?
I don't.
I don't because I just got some spam from some fucking incorporation that I have
and the only people that had it was the bank.
So the bank obviously sold it to some other constant.
Now I'm getting this fucking pamphlet asking me if I want to take a fucking trip
to uh,
I dunno.
Honduras Internet providers like Verizon and spectrum can record a list of every
website you visit and they can legally give it to anyone.
It's time to stop trusting big corporations with your data and start protecting
it with express VPN.
Od.
I like this.
A little pushback with express VP and you can privately and securely surfed the
Internet without being tracked by anyone.
Set up on all of your devices,
only takes a few minutes.
The Express VPN APP runs seamlessly in the background of your desktop,
laptop and smartphone or tablet.
You're network data is encrypted and Ip address mass keeping your activity and
identity completely private.
Yeah.
Well,
what if somebody hacks into your system for less than $7 a month?
You can be protected for IX with express Vpn,
but at least you're putting up a fight.
You know,
this is like prison.
Now.
You know,
you just don't want to be the easy target.
Now move on to somebody else.
Every express VPN plan is covered by a risk free.
I'm gonna sign up for this shit.
30 day money back guarantee.
After you've experienced the freedom,
privacy and safety that express VPN gives,
you'll never going to want to use the internet again without it to take back
your Internet privacy today and find out how you can get three months for free.
Go to express
vpn.com/burr,
that's e x,
p,
r,
e s s v P,
n,
Echo ex-ray,
Papa Romeo,
Echo Sierra,
Sierra,
victor,
Papa,
nov.com/bar for three months for free.
Protect your Internet and data with express VPN today.
You know,
if politicians weren't strictly driven by money,
um,
you know,
you'd be able to go,
you should be able to go and sue everybody.
They put all your fucking information out there.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
They need to have like a lady to have stricter rules on hacking information.
You know what I mean?
We gotta act like the way they do in,
in like Southeast Asia.
When bankers step out of line,
they put them to death.
You know?
I'm not saying we got to kill these fucking people,
but like,
you know,
we can bring back the stockade,
right?
Nah,
you can't do that.
We'd be like,
we would sit there and be like,
well,
what does that make us?
We can't do things like that.
We're not supposed to be like that.
We just waterboard people water boredom.
Yeah.
There's a water waterboarding sounds.
That sounds like a fucking,
sounds like a game that you,
a toy that you would have before,
like the fucking Internet Nela cool shit came along.
You don't remember all that bad.
Those awful fucking games that we have,
at least we got outside.
We weren't fat fucks.
Do you guys remember trackball see if I can find that commercial.
It was like basically,
I think we actually bought that
track ball commercial.
See if I can find this thing
trackball by whammo.
Oh my God.
This takes me back.
It's takes me whammo whatever happened to those guys,
the Internet video games.
Oh,
this is somebody fucking play in track ball.
I want the fucking commercial.
You know?
I don't understand these people that like,
you know their kids about read a bump their head and rather than preventing it,
they let them do it so they can fucking get a youtube video out of it.
20 pictures that Hillary Clinton wish wishes would go away.
That's what I look up track ball and then that's what I get the night Ted
Nugent.
This is what you guys can,
I'm going to,
I'm going to give up my information here by the videos that just came up here.
You guys will understand what I look for
on Youtube.
All right.
Michael Angelo,
2018 rock and roll led Zeppelin tribute
the night Ted Nugent challenged Leonard Skinner.
Jonathan Moffett plays Michael Jackson's.
Billie Jean.
He's a drummer.
20 pictures that Hillary Clinton wishes would go away.
Family never believed their GRANDPA's crazy stories until,
and there's a picture of an old trunk.
The dragon takes its toll in blood is a motorcycle video.
I do watch people wipe out on motorcycles.
You guys do that shit.
I don't like watching like knockouts.
I used to like watching that shit,
but there's just too many fucking sucker punches and shit like that.
But I do like watching these fucking people on motorcycles driving like goddamn
lunatics.
I like when they run from the cops and they get away and I like watching them
wipe up.
I don't know what that says about me.
Brutal motorcycle crashes.
Part three,
part three,
4 million,
800,000 fucking video.
Look at this guy out.
Bam.
Hey,
he was going too fast.
He rode right into the fat guy in the fact that I didn't even fall down.
Now the guy,
the guy doing the front,
fucking,
this is my favorite one.
You know when they do the front wheelie there,
there's some point you have to let go and do the face plant.
Good Dude.
I swear to God.
People on motorcycle [inaudible] just a different breed.
Yeah,
there's a level of balls.
There's a lot of fat guys on motorcycles right now.
You know,
that has to affect a center of gravity of the bike.
It's got to bring it up higher.
Right?
That's probably why this guy just went down.
Okay.
Is another guy going into a turn?
Everything's going good.
There's snow on the ground.
What could go wrong?
This is the last one.
I'll do it cause I know this is getting boring here.
Anything I can do to avoid talking about how miserable I was watching the last
two fucking Bruins games.
Um,
what's going to happen?
Is it dear gonna come running out.
This guy seems to be riding very responsibly.
He's checking out all the beautiful,
uh,
areas.
Is he going to hit get hit by a Santa Claus' sleigh?
Ah,
we hit the ice and he goes down.
Oh,
that sucks.
Well,
what the fuck were you thinking when he was a guy in a track?
Is a smart guy.
Why don't more people go out to a track?
There's no branches are fucking SUV is out there.
Um,
all right.
I'm done with that shit I'm speaking of which I got to get my truck tuned up.
Get that fucker ready for the summer out here.
Get that fucker ready for the summer out.
Um Oh.
By the way,
I'm having a very special guest coming out to the podcast next week.
A very special guest to promote their new show berry on HBO.
It's going down next week.
Very special guests.
We'll be coming onto my repeat,
very special guests.
He can look forward to that.
I have a week of shows coming up out in San Francisco Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
There was another show that I was announced on some sort of benefit I saw on
Twitter.
I don't even know what the fuck that is.
My agent called me up asking me if I knew what the fuck it was.
Nobody knew what the fuck it was.
I'm not going to be doing that benefit.
Why would I schedule an a competing show in a fucking hour,
right?
Yeah.
Christ,
they're going to call this person back.
All right,
well listen,
that was the fucking podcast.
Jesus Christ.
You know something?
I literally literally found this one in.
I spent 10 minutes talking about a fucking sign that I thought the neighbors
were bitching about.
It turned out it was a fucking horse farm.
Um,
was there anything accomplished?
I defended Michelle Wolf.
Okay.
How about that?
Without ever seeing what the fuck she said,
I don't even give a fuck you,
you're told jokes.
It's like getting mad at a plumber cause they came over to your house and,
and,
and plumbed.
You get offended by the way they sneak out of fucking toilet.
Um,
I think that's all I did really.
Is that all I did?
Well,
you know,
what do you want from me?
You know what's cool with seeing Pedro Martinez at the Bruins game?
I wish the Bruins and I mean,
Boston teams would do that more.
You know,
our legends just like disappear.
He need to have them come back around and talk to the younger people about the
fucking,
even if it's from another sport,
it's still great just to see a champion.
There was Bobby your and Pedro Martinez.
Um,
yeah,
black.
I always bothers me like Larry Bird.
Like he just like left.
He never see the guy come back.
But you know,
he was always like that.
Right?
He always wanted to go back to the country,
just be left alone,
you know,
there's a bunch of billboards,
a couple billboards out here.
These fans put up asking Lebron to come out here.
I mean,
that's how hard people go out here.
It's how much money they got.
You know,
they can just pay for billboards,
all these fucking wine and as Laker fans,
because they've been bad for a couple of years,
give us the best player.
It's all they fucking threw out here.
Drives me nuts.
Um,
you know,
it's just a Celtics can't compete with that.
I've been saying this for years.
This is our pitch.
Hey,
do you want to come to racist Boston
and deal with the winner in flux sixes or do you want to go to racist Los
Angeles where it's summer,
everyday in fuck movie stars and,
and,
and supermodels.
We can't compete with that.
I don't think there's one infinity pool in Massachusetts.
Do what?
I got a back yard.
Raped.
He could come over and skate on.
Um,
all right.
I got some shit to do.
Uh,
that's the podcast.
Go Bruins,
go Celtics,
Celtics game two against the 70 sixers mo cheeks.
Andrew.
Tony.
Huh?
Those are the six years.
I remember.
I'm going to be watching that tonight.
Actually.
No,
I'm going to be editing.
F is for family and then I'm going to go do a spot somewhere possibly.
All right.
That's it.
Listen to the music and enjoy another half hour of,
uh,
some Thursday afternoon podcasts from earlier this year or maybe one from years
ago.
I have no idea.
I have
a great weekend.
You console.
See on Monday you are mine re
[inaudible]
tropics.
I see.
Hi.
[inaudible]
lovely name,
yellows,
big
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and it is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
May 3rd,
2010.
Um,
how the hell are you?
I got some great news for you.
The podcast is back.
It is back up on iTunes and right now you're going to go to iTunes and you're
probably not going to be able to find it because uh,
it's gonna take three to six days for it to actually appear if you go to search
it because iTunes is a pain in the ass,
as we've noticed over the last three months.
But my new,
uh,
my new sort of web guy here has been able to fix the thing.
And basically if you want to find all the podcasts since the beginning in 2007
right up until now,
all you have to do is just go into iTunes.
And,
uh,
once you're in Itunes,
you click on advanced and it,
once you click on advanced,
uh,
what you do,
it's two down.
Click on subscribe,
subscribe to podcast,
and then this little window will open up.
And this is what you type in.
All right,
type in www dot [inaudible] dot com slash podcast and hit okay.
And um,
you know,
that'll be it.
You'll be in,
you'll have all the podcasts from here on out until the end of time unless
something happens to me because,
uh,
this is my podcast thing,
whatever the fuck it is,
I'm not with the g cast anymore.
I'm not with that Libsyn Shit.
I'm with my own thing,
so I don't have to deal with their fees.
I don't have to deal with them suddenly going on a business or switching the way
that they do things or their intellectual properties or their fucking whatever
the hell it is that they're doing.
And this is why it took me so long.
And I just want to thank everybody.
I appreciate the patience.
I even appreciate the angry emails people sent me like,
dude,
what the fuck is going on?
Um,
I appreciate all of that because that meant you give a shit and that you like to
listen to it.
So once again,
go into iTunes and at least on a Mac,
if you click on advanced the window that opens up to second thing down with say,
subscribed to the podcast,
you open that up,
a window will open and in it you will,
right,
www dot [inaudible] dot com uh,
slash podcast.
All right.
And it's the regular slash the one that starts further to the right and then
comes to,
I don't even know.
No,
no,
I don't even,
don't even try to describe a backslash.
I don't even fucking know how to tell you that.
Um,
so that's it.
And one other thing I have to hype is we have our a fan page now here on the,
uh,
Bill Burr,
a Monday morning podcast,
and that one is,
uh,
www dot the capital m,
capital m,
capital p,
and then your spelling podcast.
I'm the worst
www.themmpodcast.com and m m in the P of podcast are capitalized.
That's how so go on there.
Leave your comments.
If you want to check out some pictures of some of the fucked up references
that'll make to whatever podcast you're listening to,
there'll be up there.
I actually asked you guys some questions on there.
I haven't done that in a couple of weeks,
but finally everything should be up and running and that was probably the
driest,
most unfunny three minutes and 25 seconds I've ever done on the podcast.
But I had to get that information out there.
I'm going to send out a mass email and I'm going to put it up on Facebook and on
my space,
all that information that I just gave you.
And if you know other podcasts,
listeners,
if you want to email them what I just said,
email it to them and maybe I can,
uh,
maybe I can build it back up again.
You know,
just Kinda like a,
uh,
something that went out of business and then they was kinda like the Jay Leno
show.
I went away for a minute.
Now I'm back and I'm trying to get my ratings back again.
Granted,
I didn't kick out some unsuspecting redhead.
I kicked myself out and I am an unsuspecting redhead and speaking of redheads,
God damn,
and am I good with the fucking segues?
Somebody sent me something this week.
They sent me a video and they were like,
uh,
why don't you say that?
Like David tell a video,
somebody sent me a video and said,
you gotta check this thing out or whatever.
I don't know if you've seen this yet,
but there is a video on youtube.
Um,
are you guys familiar with the artist a mia?
She did that song,
I believe it was it paper planes.
Um,
you know,
is that song you couldn't fucking get away from last year?
What was like an awesome song?
And then every filmmaker in America seem to fall in love with it and put it in
their movie or even Salt Lake Pineapple Express.
It wasn't even in the movie,
but they still put it in the trailer.
All right.
I like paper and I like planes and I liked something and I'm fucking lame.
Ab some man.
You sound man.
You sound yes bill.
We know.
Ah,
there's,
there's one,
there's a bed cover this.
My cover of a am I is a paper planes or whatever.
I know it's not called paper planes,
it's called something else.
Something with paper in it,
you know.
So anyways,
she has a new video out that somebody brought to my attention and to hear the
relaxed confidence in my voice.
Now I feel so much better now than I know my podcast is backup on iTunes even
though for three to six days,
most of you will not know that because you won't be able to find it because you
won't have heard this.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so somebody sent me this thing,
this uh,
this video.
Um,
MIA has a new video called born free.
All right?
So they should go,
you should check this video out and it's actually a video of my girlfriend
already showed me.
She goes,
I want you to see this.
Okay.
And it just watch it with an open mind.
I don't even want you to criticize it.
Just watch it.
Okay.
Can you do me the,
he has promise me that you're not going to go,
oh gee is two seconds into it.
Can you please?
So I said,
yeah,
fine.
I'll sit down and I watch it and it's basically a,
I'm not to,
whatever,
I'm going to ruin it here.
All right,
spoiler alert.
Um,
basically the video is about,
uh,
start really army guys,
but it's more like a sort of riot police guys,
white dudes,
I think all white dudes and like riot police and they're a,
they bust into this apartment building that looks like it's in the Middle East.
It's got that Middle East sort of a vibe to it.
Um,
which basically means a,
you know,
there's some bullet holes with some sand in the background.
To me that's the Middle East,
you know,
could be Miami.
I don't fucking know.
Right.
So I'm,
I'm watching this thing and they basically,
they just go through this,
this apartment complex,
just horrifically kicking in doors,
violating everybody's rights.
They don't give a shit what people are doing because they're looking for this
one dude and they find the dude and they grabbed the guy right as redheaded
white dude,
sort of a buzz cut I guess.
And they grab him.
He doesn't want to go in there fighting them.
And they bring them downstairs and then they put them on a bus and he gets on
the bus and it's a whole bunch of other red heads.
It's a whole,
it's a whole bus full of red heads.
All right.
And I'm right there.
I was like,
oh Jesus.
But I didn't say anything because I promised by lovely girlfriend I'd watched
the whole thing.
So long story short,
they drive him to a camp,
they have him get off the bus and then they make them run so that all the police
can basically kill them and they have them run through minefields and all that
type of shit.
And it's basically commenting on the racial profiling,
the genocide,
and some of the stuff that has gone on in the past and has gone evidently going
on right now.
All right.
It made no references to Iraq,
but it definitely had a I rec sort of a feel to it,
except it was redheads so on the air.
And my girl was like,
well what did you,
and then like these red heads,
they're fucking arms are flying off.
All right.
They're beaten him with clubs.
They're doing all this horrific shit to him,
to this sea of red heads.
And she said,
what did you think?
And this is basic,
and I'm also answering this,
a person who sent it to me,
what I thought of it.
I thought it was a great idea for a video and I thought it could have made a
good point if they didn't pick the singled out group of redheads for the simple
fact
that,
uh,
nobody gives a shit about red heads.
Yeah.
We're just,
I don't know what it is.
People don't,
they,
they just don't care about us.
You know,
I remember when Kanye West was saying,
you know,
George Bush doesn't care about black people.
Well,
nobody cares about white people.
So you know,
at least somebody cares about black people.
It's just George.
George doesn't,
you know,
but there's,
there's people who do,
that was my thing.
The second they decided redheads,
it just became a comedy.
And I got to admit it was weird because I've never seen a busload of redheads.
It dawned on me,
I've never seen that.
Like I've seen a bus load of like,
you know,
generally speaking,
you look on a bus,
it's a bunch of people with brown hair,
the occasional blonde,
right.
And uh,
you know,
maybe a red head every five buses,
there'll be one red head.
But an entire busload of redheads was funny to me and all [inaudible] also,
it was oddly disturbing.
It was,
they were weird looking and I realized in that moment,
even as a redhead,
I'm going,
this are those weird look and sons of bitches and I realized that this is the
deal with red heads.
We are not the main course.
We are a spice.
We are the spice in like,
uh,
I dunno,
we like red pepper flakes that you put on like I don't know,
a steak or something.
If you ordered something in a restaurant and all they brought over was the
spice,
you'd be like,
dude,
what the fuck was the meal?
That's what,
that's what red heads do.
That's our job with people.
You go to a baseball game and you just sit in there going,
Jesus Christ,
how many fucking Brunettes can I look at?
Bam.
As a redhead.
Oh Shit,
there's a red head.
Right.
Reset your brain and he can,
we'll look at some more brunettes now.
That's what we do.
So a long story short,
that's what I thought I thought about the video.
I thought it was a,
uh,
just cause they pay,
I don't know who else they could have picked.
I understand what they're saying.
What if they rounded up this certain segment of white people?
Would you give a fuck now?
You know,
I guess,
you know,
as always,
I,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
But like,
because it was red heads,
I just felt at that point,
the second they started running through the minefield,
they should've had a,
they should have had like Benny Hill music,
wham,
wham Bam.
Back a day.
A day at the end is they blew them up.
Cause I just was funny to me and weird.
It was oddly like if you were walking down the street and all of a sudden like
just a group of redheads was just walking the other way.
You can't tell me that you wouldn't be creeped out or uncomfortable just for the
mere fact that you've never seen it.
See it.
Like those are my fucking people.
And I saw them all together and I was weirded out by it.
Okay.
Am I a self hating red head?
I don't think I am.
I just,
I dunno.
So check it out.
It's called,
uh,
you want to see a bunch of red heads get,
get beat up and blown up.
There you go.
I mean,
fucking South Park did that shit way was Kika Ginger Day and kids actually did
it.
They actually went out and fucking did it.
You couldn't have that upon any other group without some sort of outrage,
you know,
flip some Jewish guys balls day.
You can never have that.
They'd be,
they'd be considered antisemitic.
Could be taken off the fucking air.
If you said something about black people,
you know,
redheads,
I dunno,
we fall into those weird cracks where were white dudes,
so no one gives a shit.
But uh,
are we a silent minority?
I used to bits about that.
How redheads are portrayed in the movies.
You know,
we're never the cool guy.
We never out.
We're always the friend with a guy in the van.
You know when Tom Cruise is in that gone,
you know,
I'm like sitting there in a van and a laptop.
He's,
he's running around with like fucking Halle Berry or some other orange and know
you gotta give me more time and then I'm on the van.
Huh?
I'll try.
You know,
and I'm clicking away on my laptop.
That's what I'm doing.
No Pussy,
no sunshine,
no pussy.
Okay.
Since the beginning of filmmaking.
Huh?
Richie Cunningham.
Howdy duty.
David Caruso was our only fucking shot and he blew it.
They fuck,
I just talk about this shit on stage.
You fucking blew it.
So I mean,
I don't know.
That's just how we're,
uh,
outweigh where Eric Stoltz came close.
He can close,
but they did the movie mask and once again reminded everybody that he was
genetically compromised.
Um,
what else
has there been one?
Okay.
Even like Shaun White,
the baddest snowboard in the world.
Would they call them the flying tomato?
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks for that.
That fucking horrific fucking nickname.
There is no god damn respect,
you know?
And here I am a redhead myself and I watched that video and I thought it was
funny.
We thought it'd be funny.
Remember that Joe Piscopo when he used to do Allen Funt we thought it'd be
funny.
All right,
so let's plow ahead here.
That's what I thought about that shit.
Um,
I did a lot of TV watching this week,
but I'm going to try to get back to some of the topics here on the podcast.
Oh,
here's a little story for you.
I was going to tell you,
I forgot,
I've actually already recorded this podcast and recorded it last night,
but I was tired and I was grumpy.
I was in a bad mood because I had another incident with my downstairs neighbor,
the continuing story of the downstairs fucking neighbor.
And for those of you who are new to my podcast,
I have a neighbor downstairs,
classic,
you know,
old guy.
And uh,
we have hardwood floors and he thinks we make entirely too much noise and he
fucking hates us.
So,
um,
but I confronted the guy so he doesn't yell at us anymore.
And uh,
yesterday I was a hanging out and I was doing what most people of my age to 41
years old.
What do you do?
A,
you helping out your wife,
you taken the kids to the park.
Fuck.
Now you're not even married.
You don't have kids.
You know what you're doing.
You just,
you're taking your LP of,
for those about to rock that you just bought
and you're putting it on your turntable because you know that Angus is always in
the right speaker and Malcolm is always in the left and you want to learn the
rhythm to evil walks.
That's all I wanted to do.
People,
I wasn't hurting anybody.
All right.
And,
and for underrated,
overrated.
Very underrated.
ACDC album is the,
for those about to rock.
The problem was is they will have following the back in black album,
but if there's any guitar players out there,
he got to fucking listen to the,
to the B side of that album.
All right.
Evil walks,
cod,
um,
the whole,
the whole backside.
I love him.
Tournament,
what the,
what the last song is on that one.
Mm.
I can't do nothing.
Right under Dan had a spell bound as another great one and it's just,
I dunno,
I,
it's still the craziest thing where now that I've started playing guitar is I am
finding a whole nother genius level to ACDC music that I've now been listening
to for 30 fucking years if he can believe it.
Malcolm is an APP in Angus,
they're fucking geniuses.
So this is all I want to do is,
you know,
I'm never going to be able to,
well who knows,
maybe if I play till I'm 65 I'll actually be able to play a couple of Angus
leads if I stick with it.
But like I just wanted,
that's why I started playing guitars.
Like I just want to be able to play the shit that Malcolm place,
just the rhythm underneath,
right?
So that's all I'm doing.
I'm sitting there with my fucking my phone or graph,
my record player,
my stereo,
whatever you want to call it.
And I'm getting ready to switch the balance all the way over to the left.
So I can figure out what,
what Malcolm is doing.
What the fuck does Malcolm do that makes you,
if you end the last row of the fucking Roman Coliseum,
he still blowing you out of the back of the thing.
You know,
it's all about not playing the high d with those guys.
They're fucking maniacs anyways,
so this is what I want to do.
So I switch it over to the left side and I find out my left side speakers fucked
up.
Oh my God,
Jesus Christ.
So I'm trying to fix the thing and as I reached behind it and I got this little,
I don't know what it is,
you plug the speaker into this little,
it's like the size of like a matchbox car,
right?
And I knock it out and it hits the floor.
Boom,
hits the floor.
I was like,
I literally made that face like,
you know,
cause I don't want to piss off the fucking bear downstairs,
right?
So he doesn't yell us anymore.
You know what this Douche bag does?
He gets up,
don't,
don't go my hair and walking over to his door and he opens up his door and then
slams.
It is hard as he can.
And I really wish that I was mature enough as,
as an adult to just laugh that off.
But it made me so fucking mad because I literally feel like this is like the,
the,
um,
I'm walking around on egg shells,
male goddamn apartment,
you know,
here I,
I dropped,
I dropped one fucking thing all day and I let her go.
Like,
oh my God,
what did I do?
I'm literally on eggshells because,
and you know,
and,
and this is what always happens to me.
I always get on egg shells around people.
Initially.
That's my initial reaction when someone's a dick is I kind of back off a little
bit,
you know?
And then I,
then I always go into,
wait a minute,
what are you really tiptoeing around?
Or whatever the fuck it is I'm doing.
And then I get mad.
And,
uh,
so that's what happened with that guy.
And it's just,
it's just like,
I don't know how to solve this.
It's an old guy.
I can't yell at him.
I just can't.
It's like,
it goes against how I was brought up.
It's common decency.
He's an old son of a bitch.
Whatever.
He's fucking miserable.
But he keeps doing this,
this fucking Alpha male shit.
Well,
you slamming the door like,
like,
I dunno if I'm wrong to read it that way.
Like,
like what do you think is some sort of fucking bad ass?
Remember that commercial where you want to dance all man,
you want to fucking dance?
If I feel like doing walking up in a sweat,
can I open these goddamn blinds?
It's probably going to be upset with the noise I just made.
There
you go.
Move the screen.
Ah,
fuck.
This thing's gonna slam open.
Now watch this.
So it happens every week.
There we go.
Now it's open.
Um,
yes.
So I was dealing with that fucking guy.
So anyway,
so I did a podcast last night and just the,
the anger I had for that guy was just running through the entire thing.
And I was like,
who wants to listen to an angry son of a bitch?
And I know what you're thinking,
Bell.
You know,
that's how I think he a funniest.
When you get mad,
it was a different kind of mad.
It was like a serious like,
dude,
why don't you just fucking get over it?
Kind of mad.
So,
so anyways,
oh,
here's the,
here's a story I wanted to tell you.
I had a gay little moment yesterday at a,
uh,
when I was hanging out with my girlfriend.
You know,
you have to have one of those moments,
you know,
you have,
I was,
uh,
driving back from somewhere.
Oh,
a vegetarian restaurant that my girlfriend wanted to go to.
She's like,
you want to go to,
you want to go to Eddie cucumbers?
And I'm like,
no.
But I told her I'd take her out to breakfast and then it became lunch and then
she wants to go to this fucking Vegan place.
Right.
You know,
where they have like,
you know,
the chef should literally come out and be like,
okay,
who likes impressions?
All right,
this is my impression of Bacon.
He just wheels some brown soy that he,
that he fucking,
that's all it is.
It's,
it's a bunch of,
it's soy.
Soy is like the rich little of a Vegan restaurant where it can fucking imitate
him.
Everybody,
but not quite.
It's more like rich little in the 80s,
when he stopped working on his impressions and he's,
and he was still like nightly doing like an impression of like Lyndon B Johnson.
It's like,
dude,
we're already up to the fucking first George Bush,
which we're not aware of yet,
that it is the first George Bush unless we're Marty McFly.
So anyways,
uh,
so we go there,
we fucking eat there.
Um,
and we're driving back.
She goes,
I want to get some ice cream.
You want to get some ice cream?
I knew a great ice cream place.
I said,
fuck yeah,
I love ice cream.
I love it.
I like to eat ice cream.
You know,
I'm not ashamed of it.
I know,
you know,
who doesn't like ice cream?
You know,
maybe people who are lactose intolerant,
maybe they don't like it.
People who,
who didn't floss throughout their life.
So it hurts their teeth.
You know,
this one for you youngsters brush and floss every night because if you don't,
someday ice cream is going to hurt your teeth and you'll never be able to enjoy
it again.
You know,
some day you'll have full upper and lower dentures sitting there just fucking
doing that thing.
You know,
you know,
people chew when they have dentures,
they do that thing where they look like they're trying to blow a bubble with
their food.
For some reason their tongue has to stick out like a Goddamn Lama.
You don't want to do that shit.
So anyways,
I'm like,
yeah,
let's go.
So,
um,
why am I walking around?
I don't know why I'm walking around.
What the fuck?
Why am I questioning it?
I felt like walking around,
I'm walking around.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
so we go to this,
this ice cream place and of course it's not like the old school ones that I used
to go to like friendlies and Brigham's where you just walked in and there was
like,
you know,
what do you want?
You want chocolate,
you want vanilla,
he wants strawberry.
You know,
rocky road,
they had a couple of those and I like rocky road and I'm like marshmallows.
I really don't.
They just did fucking gross that they're just,
I dunno.
Usually when something's gooey it makes it good,
like melted cheese.
But this marshmallow is a fucking disgusting,
you know?
Oh,
you douchebags out there making s'mores.
I don't what the fuck's wrong with you.
But anyways,
so we'd go to the,
we go to this,
uh,
we go to this place and we walk in.
It's one of these places now where they have all these new fucking,
I don't know what kind of flavors they got.
I was going to say funky flavors and I realized that I shouldn't use that word.
So I had to go back to fucking,
I was like,
should I say it?
Should I not say it?
Fucking flavors.
Um,
they had like red velvet cake,
ice cream.
I mean,
it doesn't even make sense anymore.
So they had another one that was like,
you know,
Carmel something and it had great nuts on the top of them.
Right.
So this is the deal.
I don't know if he'd ever been one of these designer ice cream places.
What they do is their flavors are so fucked up.
You've never had them before.
So you've got it.
You want to try them out.
So how it works is it's a scoop a little out with that little,
this little plastic spoon,
and then they hand it to you and then you eat it.
You know like,
Oh yeah,
I,
I like that one.
Let me try this one.
It's my girlfriend's doing that and it,
this dude scooping the ice cream out.
So it's like already,
it's just like weird.
Like which one you want to try.
And even like the names,
oh,
let me,
let me try the triple foofy fucking one.
Right.
So I go,
let me try the great and that one.
Right?
So we scoops a little bit out and then he goes to,
he goes down because they hand it to me and the spoon is so small,
there's,
there's like,
there's no way for me to take it from without brushing my hand and gets his
hand,
you know?
And then I also,
I have to take it in a very,
very light,
delicate way because I don't want to spill the ice cream.
So my hand grazes his hand,
you know,
like we're in lady and the tramp fucking eaten spaghetti and a hand kind of way.
Right.
And I take it from him and then I eat the ice cream and it just,
it just,
there was something about it that just felt wrong.
Okay.
I just sort of,
it was intimate.
I had an intimate moment with his hand in my hand and then I put a sweet treat
into my mouth afterwards and told them it was good.
So,
so is the best part.
So I don't give a fuck what that ice cream was.
Felt like.
I was like,
I'm taking that shit right now.
Let me get,
let me get that flavor.
Cause I don't know if I can do that again.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno.
I'll either start blushing or asked for your phone number.
I don't know what's going to happen.
So the best part was after I go,
yeah,
let me just get that great enough flavor.
My girl goes,
oh no,
you get two scoops.
Two different flavors.
What other one do you want to try?
And I'm like that one.
The one right next to it.
I don't think they go well together.
I don't give a fuck.
Can we end this?
What does that cowboy movie with a two gay cowboys in the,
uh,
Brokeback mountain moment with the ice cream we just ended.
Oh God.
I'm getting creeped out right now,
Jeff.
I'll tell you something else.
Fucking,
it was worth it,
man.
Ice Cream was unbelievable with the grape nuts on it and telling you it's worth
it.
It's worth grazing another man's hands just to try it.
It's fucking phenomenal.
Um,
so there you go.
That was my,
that was my little moment.
And uh,
the ice cream is so good.
I'm going to go there again and I'm going to try my best to get a female the
next time I have to do that.
That might get dangerous.
Right?
And then what else?
Fucking,
no,
no.
I'm going,
I'm going to go down.
I don't do sex jokes.
Okay.
The two fucking easy.
All right.
I just trashed Jesus.
All right,
so that was my gay little moment of the week.
Um,
I can't get fucking comfortable.
Why can't I?
I can't.
I'm standing up.
I'm sitting back down.
My foot feels a lot better by the way.
I want to thank that.
The,
I had a couple of doctors who actually listened to this,
or at least they say they are.
And uh,
whoever was the one who told me to take a bottle of water and freeze it in the
fridge and roll that underneath the arch of my,
it's done fucking wonders.
So pass that on.
If you have a fuck up the Archie or foot and every time he go to take a step and
it feels like there's,
there's,
there's an invisible smurf,
just stab in the bottom of your foot.
Just do a bunch of calf stretches,
almost like runners.
Stretches is what you do.
And then like,
like three,
four times a day,
just roll a frozen bottle of water underneath your arch.
It's like you're massaging it.
And icing it all at the same time.
And I gotta tell you want to talk about a fucking ice cream headache.
Take a frozen bottle of water and just stick it on the bottom of your foot.
Um,
but you know,
you get used to it,
you get fucking used to it.
So I want to thank whoever,
uh,
whoever told me to do that,
I somehow lost the email with all my web stuff this week.
Um,
but anyways,
plowing ahead here.
I have,
I have more exciting news right now.
I am currently getting ready to do my fifth,
uh,
performance on the David Letterman program.
Number five.
My fifth time going to go out there and do some stand up and,
uh,
I'm putting together the set right now.
I'm very confident.
I think everything's going good.
It's ahead of schedule.
And tonight I'm literally going to sit down and,
uh,
before I go out,
I have it all worked out and I just have to type it out.
Like my jokes are easily,
I can take the curse words out easily.
Um,
because so much of my cursing is not even necessary.
I just liked to do it.
And then,
cause I love getting the emails,
like so much of your current thing,
you don't even need it for
those fucking people who sit there and they think that clean comedy is like this
unbelievable thing.
Like highly you do it.
I just don't understand it.
You know it's,
I'm not saying it's,
it's,
it's a bad thing,
but the way people like that,
that right there,
that's a peer,
that's pure fuck.
You know what that's like watching Lawrence Welk in because they're just so
wholesome that you just think that none of those guys in that band or are
racist,
you know,
you know people who will watch clean comedy and then just think,
see right there,
that's what comedy's on Lantus Fuck.
And then those are the same people who like their neighbor ends up being a
serial killer.
Right.
And they always say the same shit.
He was so nice.
Like what is your definition of Nice?
Because they say hello to you every morning.
Good morning.
How are you?
Nice weather we're having,
he's so nice.
He always says hello.
He's or he never curses.
It's wholesome.
It's wholesome comedy.
You know?
Look at fucking Hugh Grant.
Could you get any more wholesome than that guy?
Hugh grant killed the hookers seen on sunset.
I learned that when he got busted,
they used to be hookers walking up and down the street back in the fucking
heyday.
But because that guy didn't even have the decency to pull down the fucking side
street,
the guy's got one blowing them as he goes into in and out Burger,
you know?
But you look at his movies and he plays this bumbling,
oh woo.
He's out there banging hookers so all you fucks,
I'm,
I'm sick of it.
You're idiots.
Your,
your,
your basis for somebody being nice is they say nice things,
you know?
Have you taken any psychology classes?
Have you ever,
I don't know what,
tried to break somebody down and figure out why they do the shit that they do.
Why am I yelling at all of you guys?
Like you disagreed with me?
Obviously you don't give a shit if I curse.
If you listen to this thing,
you know what I did right?
I should have been playing Catholic church music right underneath that.
That's what I was doing right there.
I was guilting you guys about something you didn't even fucking do.
What an asshole.
I apologize.
So anyways,
that's,
that's typical me.
I had great news and then I have to go negative way with it.
Um,
yeah,
so I'm going to be taping on,
um,
Monday,
May 16th,
and then I believe at airs that Friday,
which is May 20th.
So set your dvrs and all that type of stuff and I'm going to go out there and
have a great time.
So there is that.
And another big piece of news for the Trifecta here is I finally have a date in
Las Vegas.
That's right after years of people asking me on the podcast,
dude,
why don't you come to Vegas?
What's the deal man?
Um,
Tom Papa,
who is the host of the marriage ref,
very funny show on NBC.
Everybody should watch.
Good friend of mine,
Tom Papa,
wholesome Tom.
Papa does not curse in his act.
You know,
granted he's murdered half his fucking neighbors,
but Napkin.
Um,
he,
he hosts the show at the Orleans Casino in Las Vegas.
Okay.
So just go to a,
I have all the information up on my website,
[inaudible] dot com.
Um,
but it's not going to have my name on it because it's Tom Show I'm coming on and
I'm basically doing the Tom Papa comedy show.
So if you see Tom Papa,
why don't I give you the fucking dates and stop running my God damn mouth.
Uh,
I'm very excited about this date because a huge fan of Tom Papa,
a good friend of mine,
and I don't get to work with a lot of my friends anymore because they're all
headlining.
So this is a rare time that I get to work with another comedian that I respect
and am friends with a,
okay.
So it's on June 25th and 26.
It's a Friday night.
And one of the cool things about the Orleans a casino,
it's the last place where George Carlin did stand up,
see that a lot of people didn't know that.
Did they?
You didn't,
did you?
So,
uh,
there's that and that,
that ends that.
Now what the fuck did I want to talk about?
It just had a great segway there and I couldn't remember
the hell I was going to talk about Jesus Christ.
This is always happens whenever I record these things.
I have these moments.
I have these little levels and I've learned to not panic during them.
Let's talk about a show that I saw in ESPN called a 30 for 30.
It's this great new segment.
If you're a sports fan,
set your DVR and check this shit out.
Um,
they're doing stories on who killed the USFL,
uh,
the United States football league,
which I didn't,
I didn't know somebody killed it.
I just thought it didn't work out.
You know?
Um,
I actually,
a lot of people don't know this actually went to a USFL game.
I saw the Boston breakers first,
the Washington federals at Nickerson field in a,
in Boston,
Massachusetts,
in the Boston breakers one.
And it was almost a capacity crowd,
just out of curiosity and a,
I still remember a lot of the teams,
Philadelphia Stars,
the New Jersey generals owned by Donald Trump,
had Herschel walker and Doug Flutie.
Remember that shit?
Michigan Panthers won it the first year.
Bobby a bear is that who was the quarterback,
but then went and played with the saints.
Believe it or not,
I'm not looking at this shit up on the Internet.
I actually remember this stuff and my favorite fucking helmet.
I thought the Michigan Panthers had a cool helmet,
but I liked,
uh,
Oakland.
They had liked that,
that fist holding the lightening bolt on that yellow helmet.
It was the shit.
And I thought it was very fitting because the Raiders have the best uniforms and
all football and everyone's tried to rip them off.
Whenever your team becomes too pussy,
like they always go,
well,
let's fucking steal.
The Raiders will start wearing black because that's a bad ass color.
Remember Jerry Glanville,
Huh?
Speaking of marshmallows.
That dough boy,
remember that when nobody respected the Houston Oilers,
all of a sudden he gets a black satin fucking Houston Oilers jacket.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
So anyway,
so I watched one episode of it,
I can't really recommend it high enough.
I watched one on the University of Miami called the you and it was talking about
the Hay Day of the University of Miami.
Um,
it was fucking awesome man.
It was just an awesome thing on so many different levels.
Just showing how bad asked at team were,
was how crazy their team was.
And then also just watching all those old guys now exaggerating all their
fucking stories was hilarious.
And that's the great thing about being an old guy.
If you did something at eight when you retell the story,
you did it at 15 and they,
they were doing it to such a ridiculous level that I almost forgot that I was
alive when that shit was going down because it sounded like a brand new story to
me.
I mean,
granted they were not liked throughout college football and college sports in
general.
Without a doubt.
They were considered crass,
no class thugs,
all the APPS fucking lutely.
But to tell the way they tell this story,
it's,
it's just like,
and the president was like,
fuck Russia,
what's going on at the University of Miami?
I mean,
it was at the end of the day,
it's a fucking football team.
It's hilarious.
This one guy goes,
we will like Ali talking track.
Oh yeah,
you just like,
golly.
You know,
he basically brought talking shit to a whole nother art form.
He basically was the first guy to do it.
Uh,
not even on a national,
he did it on a global level and he was also stripped of his title because he
wouldn't go to war because of religious reasons.
And he stuck by it.
And you guys grabbed your Dick's after catching touchdown passes.
Oh yeah.
That's the same thing.
You,
he would just like it.
You know what this like,
it always goes back to that same quote when I see that that Bill Russell Clip,
Bill Russell was talking about his philosophies on rebounding.
I knew what the guy,
I broke the guy down I,
Bubba,
and then he's just like,
so a lot of times I got the rebound before the guy ever even took the shot,
you know,
rarely bill rally.
You could,
it wasn't really that you were six foot 10 and everybody else was a five foot
eight inch fucking white guy at that point.
Other than Wilt Chamberlain who was,
you know,
didn't everybody look like Bob Cousy,
but he's an old man now.
So he,
he get,
he gets to fuck and he gets to,
to exaggerate.
I look at Pau Gasol when they won game one,
uh,
the other night.
Oh No.
When they,
when they closed it out,
sorry,
when they closed it out against Oklahoma,
when,
Oh,
when Koby missed that,
uh,
he misses that shot and then pow,
you know,
caught the rebound and all the one motion put it in.
I can't wait.
I am,
and I mean,
it's like he's going to tell it to me.
I would love to hear him tell it later on in life,
how he's going to be like,
you know,
I mean,
did you see the look on his face?
He couldn't even believe it.
He was like,
oh my God,
Kobe's filing,
not going to yell at me on the jet ride home.
I did some good,
I did something good.
He didn't even know what to do.
It was like when Phil Mickelson finally when the masters and he jumped up in the
air and then landed on the ground and cause he felt weird.
Like he didn't,
he didn't know what to do.
He didn't know what to do.
But later on in life when that fucking old fish heads,
maybe when his head finally fucking fills out and it's round like a head
supposed to be rather than looking like the Sunday paper turned sideways.
Um,
God help me if that guy ever sees me,
I really forget that just because NBA players can throw him around that I am
only five foot 10 inches and he can fucking throw me through an Applebee's wall
upside down.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah.
When he goes to tell that story,
it's going to be fucking hilarious.
He was just,
it was a moment in the game and I knew something had to happen,
you know,
and when he let that ball go,
I knew it wasn't going to go in and something told me,
I don't know where that ball's going to come off the rim,
but I'm going to be there.
You know,
he's going to tell it like that.
That's what if,
if you're like me,
if you're in your early forties and you were around when the University of Miami
,
uh,
was winning all those titles do with the way that they taught,
you would've thought the entire country was,
was just quaking in the corner
because of a fucking football.
It was a football team was hilarious.
You know,
especially being a guy from Boston,
which is not a college sports town.
We're professional sports town.
All right?
So all we know about the University of Miami is that the fucking BC eagles beats
you on the last play of the game.
That's your bad ass team.
Fucking 65 yard goddamn prayer.
Tom Jackson says,
knock it down and you didn't
you let Gerard fail in,
sneak in behind you.
How does that happen?
How does a fucking little white dude get behind all those black guys on defense?
It's,
it's physically impossible.
Why guys can't do shit like that.
Um,
so anyways,
but definitely watch it because a,
the guy who keeps raining it in is Michael Ervin.
Cause Michael Reverend is just really fucking honest because at one point they
were saying,
you know,
the media was biased.
They will racist,
you know,
which obviously,
there's tremendous Ellen trunk mount of truth to that.
They were saying that while they were cutting to stories of these guys bringing
guns to clubs,
you know,
and then they finally cut to Michael Irving and Michael Irvin was hilarious.
He was just like,
you know,
a lot of guys say that the media was biased,
but now the truth is we,
we,
we were a bunch of bad kids.
We were bad kids.
So you know,
you can't fucking argue with the honesty.
All right,
let's get into the topics here.
I know,
I said,
all right,
youtube videos for this week.
If you sit in educatable right,
your boss has been a con today and you feel like fucking off,
you know,
sticking it to the man.
Here's a couple for you to watch.
A two quick ones.
Fuck you.
Baltimore.
That's a great one.
A parody of a car commercial and uh,
there's another one.
If you're a sports fan,
do you know like the new thing when you go to a game like the insane like flat
screen TV,
like they make some sort of intro for your team to get the crowds psyched up.
Like uh,
like picks like the,
like maybe like the Nashville predators,
how they have like that saber tooth tiger.
Maybe I'll just have like a,
you know,
computerized saber tooth tiger doing some shit with like a hockey stick or
whatever.
I got the best one ever.
That is so fucking politically incorrect.
If you guys ever wondered what a computerized polar bear would look like if it
decided to blow up the world.
And actually it actually blows up the world.
If the planet earth gets blown up by this psycho fucking polar bear.
It's the,
uh,
it's the Nanook hockey opening 2010.
That's what you want to search.
And then now nook is n a n all okay.
Hockey opening 2010 it starts with a boat.
Uh,
an icebreaking boat.
You know,
obviously it's an Alaskan team,
I'm guessing with Nanook unless it's,
I dunno,
the Yukon territory's,
I have no idea.
And there's a polar bear frozen in the ice and it it because they break up the
ice,
the polar bear gets mad,
comes up through the ice.
It's 10 times bigger than the fucking boat.
I'll just tell you the beginning and then some sort of supernatural shit happens
where it's claps its hands together.
Like Michael Clark Dunk Duncan in that movie about death row in the mouse.
Right.
And all of a sudden it has like a,
a hockey stick that's glowing like a light saber.
The thing lets out a growl and then slams it down on the ice break and ship
breaks it in half and the fucking thing sinks.
And the first thing I'm thinking was,
well what about the people on the boat,
right?
Isn't that what they'd say at the arena?
I think it's good that there's a teddy bear,
but does it have to kill people on a boat?
This thing that's just where this starts.
I don't know what happens after that.
And next thing you know,
it's in an f 16 in the fucking planet earth blows up.
This is for the beginning of a hockey game.
It's the greatest one I've ever seen.
If you're into that type of shit.
So check it out.
And the Nook hop hockey opening 2010.
All right,
let's get on with the questions for this week.
Uh,
ask bill.
Um,
very interesting question and um,
I think I might need a little bit of help on this one because this goes outside
the realms of what I've been doing with my life.
Um,
Bill,
I've been meaning to ask you,
I'm afraid that when I'm an adult and have responsibility that I will not be
able to smoke weed.
I'm not a pothead.
I smoke about a few times a week,
more in the summer.
Um,
I get decent grades at a decent school.
I feel like professional and family life won't allow me to blaze anymore.
This is what I love about this is right up until then,
right up until he says the word blaze.
I'm really,
I'm really believe in this guy,
you know,
whatever.
You know,
I smoked a couple joints a week.
I do well in school at a great school.
You know,
I'm very responsible.
I don't drink and drive it a couple times a week.
I have a,
if he said I have a couple of Tokes,
no big deal,
I get it.
You know,
you want to watch Laverne and Shirley and he'd fiddle faddle I don't have a
problem with that,
you know,
but once you say blaze,
I'm just a,
that's at least isn't that like blunt level?
Cause I always just,
I mean I'm not pothead.
I don't even smoke this shit.
So I just picture blaze meaning that there has to be some sort of significant
source of fire to get that joint going.
Like it's that big.
Maybe I'm wrong because I'm a booze hound.
So anyways,
he goes,
do you think this is true?
Do you think anyone,
uh,
do you know anyone your age or older who do smoke
decent grades at a different,
at a decent school.
Okay.
Do you know anyone your age or older who do smoke?
All right.
Um,
the,
this is my feelings on,
on weed.
I don't think it's that bad.
Especially nowadays we can get like a vaporizer,
check that out or go to a,
the,
mm,
what is it?
www.themmppodcast.com.
And they'll have a picture for you.
I guarantee it.
Um,
a vaporizer is basically you have,
you put the weed in there,
you light it on fire or whatever the fuck you do.
And it basically filters out everything except what gets you high.
Now that has to be way more healthier than sitting down and finishing a six
pack,
isn't it?
I guess it depends if you get the munchies and then he'd go out and eat cake and
ice cream.
I have no fucking idea.
But anyways,
I think,
yeah,
I,
there's,
you know,
I know people who are married and have kids and uh,
if he once in a while they go out,
send their kids to bed,
have a couple of puffs,
but you know,
you know,
kids,
they'll figure out what you're doing.
That's the only thing you have to really hide it because,
uh,
I don't,
I don't think I would smoke weed in front of my kids ever because even though I
don't think it's any worse than having a beer,
it isn't,
it really isn't.
Um,
the thing is is you are knowingly breaking the law and it is considered like,
you know,
you're on drugs for,
for some reason alcohol isn't,
which is complete bullshit,
but it is.
So just do that in front of a kid and you know,
kids,
they always want to outdo you.
They see you drinking a six pack.
They're going to try to go for,
you know,
at least eight to 12.
I don't know.
So I would just be worried this is with no psychological,
you know,
psychology background or any of that shit.
I would just think if you,
if your kids saw you smoking weed,
that he would be smoking weed by at least seventh or eighth grade,
maybe 10th if he was a fucking nerd at that point.
But um,
and then I don't think it would be that big a leap to coke.
I really wouldn't.
Now I know.
Potheads this is like a fucking big thing with you guys.
Well that's just bullshit.
It's just bullshit to do proof you to fucking gateway drug.
Really.
I think it is because everybody I know went that route.
You started off with booze,
then you went to weed,
then you went to coke and whatever else.
So you are weed.
You went to coke or they had crank.
Anybody remember that shit?
Um,
and whatever else you did took pills,
whatever you did,
you were just like,
whatever is acid.
But you always went,
we'd first,
I mean,
as far as I know,
that's how,
uh,
people who I didn't hang out with in high school did it look at me still being a
fucking friend,
not throwing anybody under the bus.
Um,
oh to it.
Speaking of that,
I'm back back in my hometown this weekend.
Really excited.
Thursday and Friday.
I'm at the Wilbur Theater.
Friday night is already sold out a Thursday night.
Tickets are still available.
Go to [inaudible] dot com click on the Wilbur theater for Thursday,
May 6th for tickets.
I'm really whoring myself out this week.
And um,
yeah,
I'll be in Atlantic city on Saturday night during the Trump Taj Mahal.
Um,
anyways,
so yeah,
that's my answer.
I think.
Yeah,
you can easily continue to smoke weed.
Just be open and honest with the person that you're with and just say,
look,
you know,
I don't smoke it every fucking day.
Uh,
I just would rather do that than have like 12 beers and become a fat fuck,
you know,
so that's what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to buy a,
I don't even know what the,
what the,
what the quantity is.
If you smoke twice a week,
what would you need?
How much would you need?
Would you need a couple of buds for that?
Get you through it?
I don't know.
Just a couple of bucks a month.
That's all.
That's all I'm going to do,
sweetheart.
All right.
Don't look at me that way.
Okay.
I'm a smart guy.
I went to a smart school and uh,
you know,
do you know anyone your age or older who do smoke?
Um,
all right.
That's it.
That is it for that.
Let's move onto the next thing.
Uh,
what are we going here?
He built,
it's been about two weeks since the April 19th podcast.
When you said you wanted the listeners to ask you the following question,
if I happen to be a comedian,
what are the general rules if I am opening for the headlining act?
Ah,
right.
Uh,
yeah.
I did not have a good time that weekend,
so yeah,
this is what you would want to do yet.
Just go up and do your act within the allotted time you're given.
If somebody tells you to do 25 minutes,
do 25 minutes and do your act.
If you want to blow me off the stage,
go up there and absolutely fucking destroy with your jokes.
If you want to try and make it hard on me as a comedian.
If you want the club owner to be looking at you going like,
this guy's going to headline someday,
that's the way you do it.
You go up there,
you do your act and you fucking destroy and you make it hard for me.
All right?
That's the ideal.
Okay?
Now there's other,
there's,
there's some headliners out there that tell like,
you're basically another thing,
uh,
as,
as courtesy to the closing act is you're not overly dirty and you don't play
with the crowd.
That's another,
that's another thing.
You know,
there's other people they say don't go in the green room.
some people who was like fucking divas,
they don't want anybody in there or they're tired and then there's other
headliners who won't even let you sell shit.
You know,
sometimes feature acts come up to me and like I have yo yo,
this guy saw my yoyos.
Some headliners don't yell at you.
Do that.
So this is my shit.
I don't give a fuck how dirty you are cause I'm filthy.
I don't give a shit.
You can talk to the crowd.
I don't give a fuck.
He can come in the green room,
you can sell your shit afterwards.
I don't give a shit.
Just do your time.
Just stick to your fucking time.
All right?
Don't go up there and do when you're supposed to do
20 to 40 minutes and say,
Oh hey,
sorry about that.
And then I say,
okay,
that's cool.
Whatever.
We all do that every once in awhile.
And then the next night on the late show,
you do 37 minutes and you're talking to the crowd and you say means shit to him
and you're not really killing,
but you're not bombing.
You just,
you know,
this is a technique that some features do to try to make the headline or look
bad is they go over their time and they fuck with the crowd and they're overly
dirty or they'll say mean stuff and it's basically they're blowing out the
parameters of the show and then they're also,
they're making the crowd tired,
you know,
and uh,
so then when you go up as,
as,
as the act,
rather than having a crowd that's ready to go,
they're already worn out.
You're coming up there and the energy is like,
you've already been up there for a fucking half an hour.
That's like how tired they are.
And uh,
that was basically the scenario that I was in.
There's this guy did 40 and then he did 37.
And then when I said,
dude,
what the fuck?
That's such,
that's two out of three shows.
He then hit me with the brilliant,
oh,
how much time do you want me to do?
You know,
which is like an open miker question.
This guy was actually older than I was.
Okay.
You know the club told you how much time to do so either you're deliberately
trying to make it difficult on me by boring the shit out of this crowd for an
extra 20 fucking this guy supposed to do 20 minutes.
He did 40 he's doing twice as time.
Um,
yeah,
it was one of those deals.
Either that or a,
I don't know what your deal is.
I don't know.
I was not able to figure this guy out and it was actually a sad thing because he
was a smart guy and he had good jokes and he should've just done m and a even
like Saturday night.
Then he goes up there and then he did,
he did like 14 minutes
and I was just beside my,
so now I've got to cover an hour and 15 rather than just doing his 20 minutes.
And I go up there,
you know,
and I do my hour,
hour and 10 now he is up there for,
you know,
like 12 minutes or some shits and now I've got to cover the rest of it and it's,
it's,
I just wanted to be like,
dude,
what is your problem?
You know why you don't have a watch?
You know,
you've been doing this shit long enough.
I know you headline.
I know,
you know what it's like when somebody does that amount of time in front of you.
So I dunno,
I just basically after,
uh,
after he said,
what did he say?
How much time do you want me to do?
I just basically stopped talking to him for the rest of the weekend because,
uh,
it was just like,
I can't explain it when it,
when somebody asks a question in what they're really saying is,
I think you're a fucking moron.
That's basically what he was saying.
Like you're going to be three shows into the weekend and the comedy club never
told you how much time to do in front of the headlining act.
You know,
and you never asked in three shows in,
you don't know where the light is.
And you already went over on the first show when you apologize for it and then,
then you fucking do it again.
And it's like,
yeah,
that's either you're a moron or you just don't give a shit.
And this guy was not dumb.
So either he didn't give a fuck or he was doing it on purpose,
which is how I took it.
I took it like this guy is doing this on purpose to make me look like an
asshole.
But fortunately I'm a fucking beast and I had no problem following the guy,
but it was just bullshit.
I didn't,
I felt like I was going on up after like a fucking telethon and for all you
young comics out there,
I know you're not gonna.
It's a stupid fucking thing to do because I actually would have said Nice things
about the guy cause he had good jokes and uh,
but I also,
you know,
I'm not going to go bad mouth them to be honest with you.
I don't even remember his fucking name,
you know?
I don't even remember his fucking name.
So that's it.
So that was my weekend.
That's what I was dealing with,
that was staying there and this guy was going over and he was like,
what you mean you don't like a bucket of shit dumped over your head before you
go up?
What?
Oh,
I didn't know that.
I've only been doing it for 20 fucking years.
I have no idea.
What are the rules?
Dia?
Just keep going until you feel like you want to get up.
What,
how do you feature for somebody?
I have no idea.
I've just been doing stand up since fucking Rita Rudner was an open miker I
don't know anything.
It was,
it was fucking ridiculous and um,
whatever,
whatever.
And I just felt like,
yeah,
why do I tell the whole story?
I felt like it,
like somebody at the club should have said something to the fucking guy.
Um,
they,
after the second time,
you know,
and nobody did.
And then I'm putting a position like,
do I go to the club owner like a,
like a fucking girl and tell on the guys to do tubes.
So I,
I decided to say something to him,
you know,
and then he hit me with that shit.
How much time do you want me to do?
Gee,
I don't know.
You've been in this business 20 years was the last time you heard somebody go,
yeah,
do 37 in front of me.
Do 37 and be sure to piss off as many people in the crowd is,
is possible before I go up there that that would be awesome.
And if there's somebody drunk in the crowd,
by all means just keep going back and forth with them and turn it into an
absolute shit fest before I go up there.
That would be great if he could go do twice the amount of time that they told
you to do and act like you have no fucking idea that would that,
yeah,
that's what I want.
That's what I'm looking for.
I'm sure that that's what you're looking for when you go out and headline.
All right.
I got a little upset there.
Um,
so that was my experience.
So there you go.
That's what you're supposed to do.
All right.
You know,
just go up there and do your fucking act and if you kill the guy after you
cannot follow you,
he'll have no reason to complain because you didn't fuck with the crowd.
You weren't dirty.
You just did you shit and he couldn't follow you.
That's the deal.
All right,
so we're going to end with this one.
Uh,
somebody asked me a hypothetical question that I think this is a new topic here.
Hypothetical's a little hypothetical for you.
Uh,
if something happened to your dog and she needs an operation that's going to
cost 50 grand,
but there's only a 65% chance that she'll survive the operation.
Do you pay apps a Fuckin lutely absolutely.
I pay twice that
absolutely.
65%.
Absolutely.
Put my mortgage down on that.
She's a fucking pit bull.
She's a warrior.
You know,
that's my buddy.
Absolutely.
Come on.
You know,
you know my dog.
My dog might do a lot of things,
but you know what,
it wouldn't do.
It wouldn't go up and do 37 minutes in front of me.
It wasn't okay because there's a loyalty to a pitbull that,
that son of a bitch didn't have when I was out there.
All right.
Ah,
fuck.
I ran out of time.
You know what I forgot to do?
I forgot to do the whole,
uh,
the whole bad covers,
the worst covers you've ever heard.
I gotta,
I gotta I gotta break out that list next week to you guys are sending me some
great ones.
One that I can remember off the top of my head was,
um,
was when earth wind fire did a,
did a cover of Paul Mccartney.
I think he was with the Beatles.
That got to get you into my life.
And it was a song that when the Beatles did it,
or Paul Mccartney,
I forget,
it was a great song,
you know,
and when earth,
wind and fire did it,
they somehow turned it into this smooth jazz sort of,
uh,
you hear the song and you start moving your head like those dudes in night at
the Roxbury.
It's just,
it's one of the worst.
The harmonies,
Ah,
God to get into my lane,
but I bought up a Ba.
It's fucking horrible.
And it's no excuse because it's a big,
it's like fucking like 27 black guys weren't earth,
wind and fire.
You would think one of them would be like,
hey,
this kind of sucks.
You know,
how the hell did we pull this off?
This sounds like somebody white did a cover of this.
That's how fucking awful it was.
All right.
Anyways,
that was the a,
that's a podcast for this week.
Sorry if it was a little bit late this week.
But,
uh,
once again,
all you have to do if you want to get the podcast is a,
you know what you have to do.
Listen to the beginning of this podcast.
Goddamn,
and I've already told you,
you go to Itunes,
click on advance.
This is on a Mac.
You go down,
scroll to down to the subscribed podcast,
and you type in www dot [inaudible] dot com slash podcast and you're in,
and you got them all,
and then they're going to be here from till the end of fucking time.
All right?
That is it.
God bless all the it.
Thanks for listening to the podcast and I'll talk to you next week when I'm out
in Boston.
All right.
[inaudible]
whoa.
you are
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
You mine.
[inaudible] oh,
[inaudible].